ces derniers jours une polémique
une de plus à la proche des élections
départementales et régionales a surgi
des réseaux sociaux pour se retrouver
dans tous nos médias parcours habituel
de la polémique sur un thème tout autant
habitué des querelles partisanes les
signes religieux et cette fois la
querelle a eu lieu à l'intérieur même
d'un parti politique
la république en marche son délégué
général stanislas guérini s'est ému de
voir une femme voilée sur une affiche de
campagne de son parti à montpellier et a
réclamé à ses candidats de retirer tout
signe religieux ostentatoire des
affiches de campagne
la députée aussi lrm naïma mucho a réagi
tout aussi vivement en estimant qu'
écarter une femme au motif qu'elle est
voilée serait discriminatoire
sauf que la députée du val d'oise se
trompe car l'investiture d'un candidat
dans le cadre d'une élection politique
n'est pas soumise à la législation sur
les discriminations la personne investie
pour se présenter aux élections au nom
d'un parti politique n'est pas un
employé de ce parti ni candidate à une
embauche ce qui exclu l'application du
droit du travail concernant les
discriminations et c'est la même chose
pour le droit électoral
le principe de neutralité religieuse ne
s'applique pas aux candidats eux-mêmes
et encore moins à la procédure interne
de choix des candidats à ce qu'on
appelle les investitures
une des conséquences c'est qu'il
n'existe pas de liberté d'expression
dans un parti politique car chaque
responsable ou candidats s'expriment au
nom de ce parti et doit donc en
respecter la ligne sous peine
d'exclusion
en somme le parti peut interdire tout
signe d'appartenance religieuse sous
réserve toutefois que cette exclusion
soit réellement justifiée par la ligne
politique et pas par d'autres raisons
car là est bien on retomberait dans la
discrimination au sens pénal mais là on
questionne toute la ligne lrm sur la
laïcité une ligne qui ressemble plutôt à
un brouillon